N
WASHINGTON. UKRAINIAN TROOPS ARE
FIGHTING TO KEEP A LIFELINE OPEN
FOR THE EMBATTLED CITY OF
MAHMOUD. CNN TEAM REPORTS NEAR
CONSTANT ARTILLERY FIRE IN THE
TOWN OF HOW CVR KEY SUPPLY ROUTE
. THE FIGHTING SUGGESTS
UKRAINIANS ARE WORKING HARD TO
KEEP RUSSIANS AWAY FROM THAT
ROAD AS THEY TRIED TO REGAIN
GROUND AND MAHMOUD. MEANWHILE
UKRAINE SAYS ITS ENERGY SYSTEM
HAS BEEN STRUCK BY MORE THAN
1200, RUSSIAN ROCKETS AND DRONES
. THAT STATEMENT DIDN'T SAY OVER
WHICH PERIOD OF TIME BUT THE
ENERGY GRID HAS BEEN REPEATEDLY
TARGETED FOR MONTHS. AND WE'RE
HEARING PERSONAL STORIES FROM A
GROUP OF UKRAINIAN CHILDREN WHO
WERE ALLEGEDLY DEPORTED BY
RUSSIA. MORE THAN 30 OF THEM
RETURNED TO UKRAINE ON FRIDAY
AFTER SPENDING MONTHS IN RUSSIA
AND OCCUPIED CRIMEA. CNN'S NICK
PATON WALSH WAS THERE WHEN THE
CHILDREN WERE REUNITED WITH
THEIR FAMILIES. JUBILANT SCENES
IN KIEV AS UKRAINIAN NGO SAVE
UKRAINE RETURNED HOME A NUMBER
OF CHILDREN WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH HELLISH MONTHS IN A VERY
SECURITIES ROUTE OUT OF OCCUPIED
PARTS OF UKRAINE, HELD BY RUSSIA
BACK THROUGH RUSSIA PROPER
ITSELF, UM BELARUS INTO UKRAINE
ITSELF. SOME OF THESE CHILDREN
ACCOMPANIED OUT ON A RESCUE
MISSION BY THEIR OWN PARENTS.
SOME OF THESE CHILDREN GUIDED
OUT BY THE PARENTS OF OTHER
CHILDREN WHO HAD THE POWER OF
ATTORNEY FROM THEIR OWN FAMILIES
TO BRING THEM BACK TO UKRAINE
PROPER. WE SPOKE TO ONE MOTHER
AND SON ARENA AND BOGGED DOWN
FROM HEAD OFFICE ON ONE OF THE
FIRST PART OF UKRAINE TO BE
OCCUPIED BY RUSSIA, AND SHE
RECALLED HOW HORRIFIED SHE'D
BEEN STRUGGLING TO GET THROUGH
TO HER 13 YEAR OLD SON, FINALLY
REACHING A TEACHER. DESPITE THE
APPALLING PHONE CONNECTIONS,
HERE'S WHAT THEY HAD TO SAY. WE
WERE DRIVING HERE FOR NEARLY A
WEEK, AND I MET MY MOTHER FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN SIX MONTHS. WE
WENT TO THE SUMMIT CAMP FOR TWO
WEEKS, BUT WE GOT STUCK THERE
FOR SIX MONTHS. WHY SHOULD I CRY
NOW? BUT I CRIED WHEN I SAW MY
MOM FROM THE BUS. I'M VERY HAPPY
TO BE BACK. THERE WAS NO PHONE
CONNECTION. I WAS VERY WORRIED.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING, WHETHER
HE WAS BEING ABUSED WHAT WAS
HAPPENING TO HIM? I WAS CALLING
HIS TEACHER ASKING FOR AT LEAST
FIVE MINUTES JUST TO HEAR MY
SON'S VOICE TO MAKE SURE HE WAS
ALRIGHT. MY HANDS ARE STILL
SHAKING DOWN THERE. VERY
CAVALIER FLIPPING AND SEEMS TO
HAVE SORT OF WASHED OFF HIM OR
THE FEAR OF THOSE MONTHS, BUT
STILL CLEAR THAT FOR SIX MONTHS
HE WAS HELD AGAINST HIS WILL AND
PART OF A NUMBER OF STORIES WE
HEARD OF THESE RESCUED CHILDREN
DEPORTED HELD AGAINST THEIR
WORLD SOME FURTHER INSIDE RUSSIA
IN OCCUPIED PARTS OF UKRAINE,
PART OF THIS PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR
THAT'S BEHIND THE INTERNATIONAL
CRIMINAL COURT'S INDICTMENT
AGAINST RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND HIS ENVOY FOR
CHILD WELFARE, SAYING THIS IS
HAPPENING, ACCORDING TO UKRAINE
ON A SCALE OF POSSIBLY TENS OF
THOUSANDS. OF CHILDREN BUT
STARTLING SCENES OF JUBILATION
HERE AS ITS NGO CONTINUES TO TRY
AND BRING TO LIGHT THROUGH SMALL
NUMBERS OF CHILDREN RESCUED AND
BROUGHT BACK TO UKRAINE. QUITE
FRANKLY, THE HORROR OF THESE
FAMILIES FORCIBLY SEPARATED BY
RUSSIA DURING THEIR INVASION.
NICK PATON WALSH. CNN KIEV,
UKRAINE. THE WOMAN ACCUSED OF
THE BOMBING THAT KILLED RUSSIAN
MILITARY BLOGGER OF LACHLAN
TUTOR SKI IS SAID TO BE
COOPERATING WITH INVESTIGATORS.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO RUSSIAN
STATE MEDIA. DARIA TRIP OVER WAS
CHARGED WITH TERRORISM OFFENSES
IN CONNECTION WITH THE TAR SKIS,
KILLING AND PUT UNDER ARREST
THROUGH AT LEAST JUNE. 2ND TRIP
OVER FACES UP TO 20 YEARS IN
PRISON. HER HUSBAND TOLD AN
INDEPENDENT RUSSIAN MEDIA
ORGANIZATION. HE THINKS HIS WIFE
WAS FRAMED. MEANWHILE HUNDREDS
OF PEOPLE GATHERED AT A MOSCOW
CEMETERY ON SATURDAY FOR TATAR
SKIS FUNERAL HE WAS ACCORDED
MILITARY HONORS, INCLUDING A GUN
SALUTE AND A MILITARY BAND.
AMONG THOSE WHO ATTENDED THE
FUNERAL WAS WAGNER CHIEF AFGHANI
PRECAUTION, A RUSSIAN DUMA
MEMBERS SPOKE. TO REPORTERS
AFTER THE SERVICE. DOUG ALREADY
TO DO, MAN. HE ALWAYS SAID WHAT
HE THOUGHT HIS LIFE WAS BRIGHT
WAS TRUE. IT WAS IT IS, AND IT
WILL BE AN EXAMPLE FOR THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO TODAY LIVE FOR
RUSSIA, WHERE PEOPLE OF
DIFFERENT VIEWS STAND SIDE BY
SIDE TOGETHER, INCLUDING PEOPLE
OF THE OPPOSITION STANDPOINT,
STAND FOR THE COUNTRY FOR ITS